[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serin guten Abend Fußball und mehr
später mit dir im sportkatja sehr gern
schön guten Abend dann blicken wir jetzt
auf unsere Themen an diesem
Dienstag die Hamas auf dem Rückzug nach
israelischen Quellen sind viele Kämpfer
der Terrorgruppe im Gazastreifen
unterwegs Richtung Süden
das Ende der Linksfraktion noch drei
Wochen dann beginnt die Selbstauflösung
unvermeidbar weil sich die Gruppe
Wagenknecht abgespalten
hat und wenn der Glaube verloren geht
acht von Zeh Menschen in Deutschland
sagen Religion habe für sie kaum noch
Bedeutung die Hamas nutze Krankenhäuser
in Gaza als menschliche Schutzschilde
war zuletzt immer wieder zu hören jetzt
präsentierte das Isra el ische Militär
Bilder die das belegen sollen und hat
offenbar auch Hinweise darauf dass viele
Islamisten gerade dabei sein in den
Süden des gaserastreifens zu fliehen
traurige Gewissheit gibt es inzwischen
zu einer verschleppten israelischen
Geisel Stefan
Schlösser Noah Mariano wurde 19 Jahre
alt die israelische Soldatin ist eine
der Geiseln die am 7 Oktober verschleppt
wurden di Heras veröffentlichte ein
Video und Fotos die no Marciano offenbar
tot zeigen die israelische Armee hat das
offiziell
bestätigt mit diesen Bildern aus dem
Keller des rantisi Kinderkrankenhauses
in Gaza will die israelische Armee
erneut belegen dass die Hamas zivile
Infrastruktur als Versteck nutzt zu
sehen sind unter anderem Waffen
Sprengstoff und noch
mehr wir haben auch Anzeichen gefunden
die darauf hindeuten dass die Hamas dort
Geiseln gefangen gehalten hat das
untersuchen wir aber
noch die Kämpfe gehen unvermindert
weiter immer mehr Menschen flüchten
Richtung Süden darunter sollen auch
hamaskämpfer sein zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung gasas etwa 1,5 Millionen
Menschen haben schätzungen zufolge ihr
zu Hause verlassen hier im Süden gab es
bisher vergleichsweise wenige Angriffe
in manchen viitteln wirkt das Leben
normal doch zusehens verschlechtert sich
auch hier die Lage vor der einzigen
Bäckerei in dieser Gegend stehen
hunderte für ein Brot
an Männer Frauen ältere und Kinder sie
weinen hier damit wir Ihnen ein Brot
geben ihre Zahl ist sehr groß und wir
können nicht mehr als etwa 500 Packungen
peterbrot am Tag produzieren heute haben
wir aber beschlossen nur noch die halbe
Menge Mehl zu nehmen so reicht es dann
für ta000
Packungen zwei Wasserversorger haben
nach Angaben der UN ihre Arbeit
eingestellt hunderttausende seien jetzt
ohne fließendes Wasser heute regnete es
inasa dafür sind die Notunterkünfte kaum
ausgelegt doch vielen Kindern brachte
der Regen eine kurze
Freude wir gehen wieder nach telav zu
Michael bwerung Michael aus der
hamasführung war zuletzt zu hören dass
man unter Umständen zu einem
geiselaustausch bereit wäre wie schätzt
du das
ein also mindestens gibt es Verhandlung
das wird auch von ganz hochrangiger
israelischer Seite bestätigt die Frage
ist unter welchen Konditionen kann ein
solcher Austausch stattfinden gestern
sagt ein her massprecher im Gespräch sei
ein Austausch von 100 Frauen und Kindern
israelischen Geiseln gegen 100 Frauen
und wohl eher Jugendlichen in
israelischen Gefängnissen dazu fordert
die Hamas eine fünftägige Waffenruhe das
wiederum wird der israelischen Armee
nicht recht sein denn sie ist gerade
dabei große Teile des gasastreifens den
nörd des nördlichen gasastreifens zu
erobern und hat dabei offenbar sehr
große Fortschritte gemacht es gibt
Berichte dass eben viele hamaskämpfer
fliehen das wird untermauert mit Belegen
aus Luftaufnahmen aber offenbar auch
geheimdienstlichen Quellen die sagen
dass hamaskämpfer im Süden angekommen
sind und die Führung hat natürlich das
Ziel einer Geiselbefreiung im Kopf aber
es ist auch die Rede von kurzfristigen
Feuerpausen aber nicht von einer langen
größeren Feuerpause vielen Dank live aus
Tel Aviv war das Michael bwerunge und
den allerneuesten nachrichtenstand den
finden Sie jederzeit auf ZDF heute
ziemlich einfach aber auch unter
Aktuelles bei Whatsapp scannen Sie dafür
einfach den angezeigten QR-Code hier
links oder abonnieren Sie uns direkt bei
Whatsapp selbst dann haben Sie alles
Wichtige vom Tag kurz und kompakt mit
den jeweiligen Updates morgens und
abends ja der narostkrieg raubt dem
Krieg in der Ukraine viel an
Aufmerksamkeit in den USA zeigen sich
schon erste Anzeichen von Kriegs
Müdigkeit und die Europäer die hinken
ihren Zusagen hinterher
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius räumte
heute vor dem eu-
verteidigungsministertreffen ein die EU
werde ihr groß angekündigtes Versprechen
der Ukraine eine Million
Artilleriegeschosse zu liefern nicht
erreichen mehr Information von Florian
Neuhann das ist die Munition die die
Ukraine dringend braucht 155 mm
Standardkaliber etwa für Panzer
produziert wie hier in Frankreich im
Frühjahr hatte die EU eine Zusage
gemacht der Ukraine bis März 24 eine
Million solcher Geschosse zu schicken
geliefert hat man bisher 300.000 und die
Verteidigungsminister müssen sich heute
fragen lassen ob sie damals zu viel
versprochen
haben die Frage ob eine Million jemals
realistisch war es wäre eigentlich die
richtige es hat Stimmen gegeben die
gesagt haben Vorsicht eine Million ist
leicht zu beschließen das das Geld ist
da aber die Produktion muss da sein die
EU-Kommission kontert EU-Regierungen
hätten zu wenig bestellt und beinah die
Hälfte der Munition werde an andere
Staaten geliefert als an die Ukraine am
Ende des Treffens eine lose
Verabredung alle waren sich einig wir
müssen mehr tun und schneller werden
denn Zeit wird hier anders gemessen in
der Zerstörung von Infrastruktur aber
vor allem im Verlust von
Menschenleben auch bei einem zweiten
versprechen kommen die Minister heute
nicht weiter die vorgeschlagene
langfristige militärische Unterstützung
der Ukraine 20 Milliarden Euro für 4
Jahre wird weiter von Ungarn blockiert
und so kommt bei manchem Frust auf
Russland produziert heute mehr als je
zuvor und sie kriegen Munition aus
Nordkorea es kann doch nicht sein dass
Russland das schafft und wir
nicht bis März so sagt ein Minister
heute werde man wohl nur eine halbe
Million Geschosse an die Ukraine liefern
können die Hälfte des eigentlich
versprochenen Bahnkunden brauchen starke
Nerven die lockführergewerkschaft GDL
hat einen bundesweiten Warnstreik
angekündigt von 22 Uhr morgen Abend bis
Donnerstag 18 Uhr sollen die
Beschäftigten die Arbeit niederlegen die
Bahn die kritisiert das scharf spricht
von einem Unding übermorgen war die
nächste Verhandlungsrunde geplant und
zum auftagt hatte die Bahn 11% mehr
angeboten bei einer Laufzeit von 32
Monaten die GDL will
555 € mehr eine kürzere
Wochenarbeitszeit und eine deutlich
kürzere Laufzeit wir gehen zum Berliner
Hauptbahnhof dort für uns Stefanie Hein
Stefanie was kommt da jetzt auf die
Bahnkunden
zu na ja ganz klar ist die Bahnkunden
werden das merken die GDL ist zwar die
kleinere Gewerkschaft im Bahnkonzern
aber in ihr sind vor allen Dingen die
Lockführer organisiert und die sind
jetzt zum Streik aufgerufen außerdem
auch die Zugbegleiter der
werkstattmitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter und wenn die Lockführer
nicht in ihre Lock steigen und losfahren
dann kann der Zug nicht fahren und genau
das ist ja das was die Reisenden merken
das wird das ist ja jetzt auch relativ
kurzfristig von morgen Abend bis
übermorgen 18 Uhr also da wird schon
eine ganze Menge äh stehen bleiben an
Zügen und klar ist ja auch wenn ein Zug
erstmal nicht losgefahren ist und dann
nicht da ist wo er hin muss dann ist er
auch wenn der Streck vorbei ist 18 Uhr
nicht da wo er dann wieder losfahren
sollte also ich würde auch
Donnerstagabend 18 Uhr nicht drauf
wetten dass der Zug den man dann nehmen
will direkt und pünktlich losfährt danke
nach Berlin Stefanie Hein im Bundestag
da fand heute etwas statt dass es so
noch nie gegeben hat in der laufenden
Legislaturperiode hat eine Fraktion
beschlossen sich aufzulösen sie ahnen es
es geht um die Linke denn die Fraktion
hat nicht mehr genug Mitglieder seit
Sarah wagen und mehrere Unterstützer
beschlossen haben die Partei zu
verlassen ohne Fraktionsstatus hat die
Linke weniger Personal weniger Geld und
insbesondere weniger Rechte im Parlament
Andrea Maurer
berichtet in Gruppenaufstellung
rahmenabgeordnete den noch Vorsitzenden
Dietmar bsch ein als der das historische
Ende der Linksfraktion im Bundestag zum
Nikolaustag
verkündet die Linksfraktion hat eben
eine Entscheidung getroffen und zwar die
Entscheidung dass wir die die Auflösung
der Fraktion zum 6.12 diesen Jahres
einleiten werden das Ende kommt also
erst nach den Haushaltsverhandlungen im
Bundestag auch damit der Fraktion noch
Möglichkeit bleibt ein letztes Mal
mitzureden einer der beiden sogenannten
Liquidatoren die die Auflösung
vollziehen wird Thomas Westfall sein
Leiter des bisherigen Vorstandsbüros das
werden also alle Sachen Vermögenswerte
der Fraktionen werden aufgenommen und
diese müssen dann so bis zum Schluss bis
also nichts mehr übrig ist von der
Fraktion also keine Technik und auch die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter dann so
ihre Kündigung erhalten haben dass diese
Liquidation dann so erfolgt dass es am
Ende sozusagen bei bei Null steht die
meisten der 108 Mitarbeiterstellen
fallen nun weg Geld und rederechte
werden weniger die Entscheidung der
Fraktion sich selbst aufzulösen ist
Reaktion auf die Ankündigung von Sarah
Wagenknecht mit neuen anderen
Abgeordneten im Januar eine eigene
Partei zu gründen was auch das Ende der
Fraktion bedeutet hätte für mich ist
wirklich das entscheidende dass wir
schnellst möglich Gruppe werden dass wir
auch deutlich machen die Linke ist
weiter im Bundestag präsent 28
Abgeordnete die sich auf ihre Arbeit
jetzt konzentrieren werden das überwiegt
natürlich da eine große Wehmut auch eine
Traurigkeit ich bin 18 jahre jetzt dabei
also ein Großteil meines Lebens weil für
bundestagsverhältnisse bin ich noch gar
nicht so alt und das ist schon ein recht
trauriger Tag für die politische Linke
insgesamt klar ist nach diesem Tag der
linke Rand im Parlament wird ab dem 6
dezember ein anderer sein ein
historischer Vorgang der Einordnung
verdient Jana Zimmermann in Berlin das
Ende der Linksfraktion nah die
verbliebenen wollen jetzt einen
gruppenstatus erlangen was bedeutet das
konkret also ab dem 6 dezember sind die
verbliebenen jetzt erstmal
einzelabgeordnete beideer Gruppen aber
sowohl die neuen rund um Sarah
Wagenknecht als auch die verbleibenden
Linken wollen je eine parlamentarische
Gruppe gründen weil sie dann einfach
etwas mehr Rechte und etwas mehr Geld
bekommen einem Ausschuss aber dürfen sie
dann immer noch nicht wieder vorsitzen
und so könnte die Union gleich zweifach
von dieser Entwicklung profitieren
erstens indem sie den sehr mächtigen
Wirtschafts und klimaausschuss übernimmt
und zweitens durch eine neue Sitzordnung
im Bundestag die Union hofft dass
mindestens eine dieser beiden neuen
Gruppen sich zwischen sie und die AFD
setzen könnte von der man im Bundestag
gerne Abstand halten möchte Dietmar Bart
den alte und wahrscheinlich auch neue
Vorsitzende der Linken im Bundestag
sprach heute viel von einer Chance auf
Neuanfang man wolle sich mehr um soziale
Probleme kümmern und auch wieder mehr
den Osten in den Blick nehmen aber die
Bühne der Linken das ist ganz klar ist
ab dem 6 Dezember deutlich kleiner
geworden und es wird sehr schwer sein
von dort gegen die Bedeutungslosigkeit
anzukämpfen danke für die Einordnung
nach Berlin Diana eine Meldung aus der
Wirtschaft lässt aufhuchen die
Bundesregierung sichert dem
energietechnikkonzern Siemens Energy mit
einer Bürgschaft von 7,5 Milliarden Euro
ab das Te das Wirtschaftsministerium mit
Siemens Energy war wegen massiver
Probleme seiner spanischen
windkrafttochter in Schieflage geraten
die staatliche Bürgschaft steht aber nur
unter Bedingungen bereit auch
Privatbanken und Siemens sollen das
Unternehmen mit weiteren Milliarden
absichern Wasserstoff möglichst erzeugt
mit Wind und Solarstrom gilt als
wichtiger Energieträger der Zukunft
Wirtschaftsminister habbeck hat jetzt
Pläne für ein Leitungsnetz in
Deutschland vorgestellt
knapp 10 000 km lang soll das Kernnetz
werden damit in einigen Jahren Industrie
und Kraftwerke versorgt werden können
auch vorhandene erdgasröhren sollen dann
genutzt werden mindestens die Hälfte des
Wasserstoffs muss dann wohl importiert
werden der deutsche Fernsehjournalist
und Autor Hubert Seipel hat 600.000 €
von einem russischen Oligarchen erhalten
der Putin nahe steht das zeigen
Recherchen des ZDF magazinson Tal und
des SPIEGEL grundlage sind geliegte
Dokumente aus Zypern seiels
Vertragspartner war danach eine
Briefkastenfirma auf den Britischen
Jungferninseln die zum Firmengeflecht
des Oligarchen gehört Seipel hat zwei
Bücher zu Putin geschrieben und eine
Fernsehdokumentation über ihn gemacht
seine Unparteilichkeit sieht er nicht
beeinträchtigt mehr zu diesem Fall heute
abend inf frontal um 21
Uhr die großen Kir in Deutschland die
wollten es genau wissen und ließen
Menschen mit und ohne Konfession
befragen und das Ergebnis ist
ernüchternd rund acht von zehn Befragten
geben an Religion habe für sie überhaupt
keine oder nur noch wenig Bedeutung und
es gibt kaum noch Vertrauen in die
Institution Kirche bei den Protestanten
sind es gerade noch
24% bei den Katholiken ist die Skepsis
noch größer hier Vertrauen nur noch 9%
ihrer Kirche über die Umfrage und die
Folgen Petra
Otto wie hast du es mit der Religion die
Gretchen Frage bei Goethes Faust und
alle 10 Jahre auch Stoff für eine große
Umfrage zur Kirche und Glauben es geht
weiter bergab zwei Drittel der
evangelischen gar dreiviertel der
katholischen Kirchenmitglieder überlegen
manchmal auszutreten Kirche oft einfach
nicht auf der Höhe der Zeit ich denke
dass es vielleicht manchmal zu Star ist
dass manche Sachen auch zu altmutisch
sind ja sie sollten bisschen so die
jungen Leute mehr ins Boot nehmen
vielleicht bisschen so eine Stunde
später noch anfangen oder so glaub nur
wenn es eine Rückbesinnung gibt auf das
was uns wirklich wichtig ist was uns
trägt dann wird's auch wieder ein
Aufschwung in der Kirche geben können
die Menschen verlieren zunehmend das
Vertrauen zur Politik wie auch zur
Kirche bei Katholikin und Katholiken ist
das besonders auffällig sie sind oft
wütend auf ihre Kirche die
hierarchischen Strukturen das Frauenbild
Kirche schweige zu oft verharere in
ihrer Blase es wird erwartet dass Kirche
zu Themen die sie betreffen aus ihrem
Grund heraus Stellung bezieht und das
tun wir auch jetzt gerade hier mit einem
entschiedenen Eintreten gegen jeden
Antisemitismus Judenhass darf bei uns
keinen Platz haben sie müssen viele
Kröten schlucken bei den Ergebnissen
ihrer Befragung die sie heute in Ulm
veröffentlicht haben umso größer die
Freude darüber dass die Menschen gerne
beten ja also zu sehen wie dieses Ritual
was ja ein ganz persönliches ist doch
für viele ein haltgebendes Momentum hat
und vermutlich gerade auch in Zeiten wo
es mal schwerer ist da kann man noch mal
gut anknüpfen Krisen ob in der Familie
oder in der Welt auch das hat die
Untersuchung ergeben machen die Menschen
ein wenig
religiöser wir sind bei Sport beim Sport
und wir sind bei Katja die Bundesliga
die Fußballbundesliga pausiert denn das
vorletzte Länderspiel steht an und das
dürfte spannend werden in der Tat es ist
ein spannendes Spielgegner ist die
Türkei Spielort das ausverkaufte
Olympiastadion in Berlin das Trainerteam
musste heute im Teamtraining auf die
leicht angeschlagenen Matz hummelz und
Leon Goretzka verzichten dafür erstmal
zusammen in der Nationalelf zwei
ehemalige Bremer Torjäger Niklas
vüllkrug seit einem Jahr Nationalstürmer
und Marvin duxch Neuling im dfbteam
beide kickten gemeinsam für Bremen dann
wechselte fükrug nach Dortmund und du
blieb bei Werder doch nun sind sie
wieder Teamkollegen die alten Freunde
gaben sich früher mal den kuriosen
Spitznamen die hässlichen
Vögel wir sind so ein bisschen unsere
eigene Art und ich find es sympathisch
es sagt das über uns aus was wir sind
und ob wir das weiter benutzen dürfen
das muss duxi
entscheiden wie ges wie schon gesagt ich
glaube das war einfach mal so a aus g
gesagt aber ja ich glaube dass wir uns
damit trotzdem irgendwie kleinen Namen
gemacht hab zwei Torjäger ein Ziel duxch
und Füllkrug wollen gemeinsam zur EM
ziemlich beste Freunde sind Sie schon
jetzt wollen sie bald auch zusammen für
das dfbteam
stürmen in der laudao hieß es er ist ein
anständiger Mensch aber Christian
Streich Trainer vom SC Freiburg ist mehr
einer mit Ecken kannten Humor aber auch
Tiefsinnigkeit und seit gestern Abend
Träger des Julius
hirschpreises schon 12 Jahre PRT er die
Bundesliga auch mit launigen
Pressekonferenzen immer meinungsstark
die generalverurteilung von Menche gibt
so lang seit Mensche gibt für seine
klare Haltung gegen Fremdenfeindlichkeit
Rassismus und Diskriminierung so DFB
Präsident Neuendorf wird er
ausgezeichnet das ist jemand der
wirklich Haltung hat der das verkörpert
typisch Streich reicht er die lohbären
weiter an die die Basisarbeit leisten da
freue ich mich wahnsinnig dass preisrieg
habe aber ich weiß dann schon wer die
ganz wichtige Leute der dienstälteste
Trainer der Bundesliga versucht auch
Werte zu vermitteln eine Tugend die
sicher nicht alltäglich ist im
Profifußball Prädikat Unikat danke schön
Kat oft sagt man ja dass sich die Welt
immer schneller dreht wir treten jetzt
mal auf die Bremse so wie das Autofahrer
in vielen Städten schon lange tun oder
tun müssen heute vor 40 Jahren wurde in
buxteehude in niedersachs die erste
Tempo 30 Zone in der Bundesrepublik
eingeführt der Erfinder damals
Stadtbaurat Otto Wicht ja und was soll
man sagen der Modellversuch von damals
ist von deutschen Straßen heute nicht
mehr
wegzudenken der Deutsche Wetterdienst
waren vor ergiebigem Dauerregen in
Teilen Bayerns und
badenwürtembergs alle Details gleich von
Christa
Orben das heute journal mit Christian
siers sehen Sie um
21:45 Uhr danke und für sie noch einen
entspannten
[Musik]
Dienstagabend guten Abend stürmisch war
es heute im Norden und auf den Bergen im
Süden gab es weiter den intensiven
Dauerregen die beiden zugehörigen Tiefs
verlieren bis morgen aber ihren Einfluss
auf uns es hat seit Sonntag wirklich
eine Menge geregnet vor allem im
berchtes Garten der Land im Allgäu und
im Schwarzwald stellenweise 50 bis 100 l
punktuell auf der krunkelbachhütte im
Schwarzwald z.B sogar
17 l Regen bis jetzt und heute Nacht
kommt in genau diesen Gebieten noch mal
10 bis 20 ler dazu vorsicht vor
Erdrutschen und Überschwemmungen zudem
frischt der Wind deutlich auf schwere
Sturmböen sind im Süden heute Nacht auf
den Bergen möglich aber auch im
Flachland wird es stürmisch Richtung
Norden lassen in der zweiten Nachthälfte
die Schauer und vereinzelten Gewitter
mehr und mehr nach es lockert mal auf
dann sinken die Temp uren auf 3° sonst
bleibt es teils bei 9° morgen liegen die
Höchstwerte zwischen 7° in
Schleswig-Holstein und 13° entlang des
reins dazu gibt's die Warmfront mit
vielen Wolken und Regen vom erdzgebirge
bis zur Nordsee ansonsten ziehen kurze
Schauer und Gewitter durch es gibt aber
auch trockene und sonnige Phase bei
einem starken westlichen Wind im Süden
mit sturmböhen auf den Bergen am
Donnerstag gibt's ein kurzes
Zwischenhoch mit ruhigerem Wetter ab
freitags wird's kühler und wieder
windiger zum Wochenende dann aber schon
wieder wärmer das war's von uns tschüss